One of the most important ways to convince people
that you're a chadwife
is by what you wear.
I found that if I can wear something really convincing,
people won't notice the holes in my cosplay.
Since I don't have time to go clothes shopping myself,
I found a personal shopper
and gave her some descriptions of what I was looking for.
Definitely 90s homeschooler,
Little House on the Prairie, and Amish.
Then she chooses clothes in the size up from what I normally wear.
So looks frumpy on me.
Sometimes we have to get it tailored just right for that perfect
frumpy look. My personal shopper charges $1,000 an hour,
but I don't actually need to hire her that often
cause I wear the same clothes over and over again in my videos.
This communicates that I'm poor,
which makes people take pity on me and buy my e books.
All in all, I think I've really succeeded the costumes for my content.
My clothes are definitely a detail people comment on the most
and most people hate them.
But you know, that just gets me more engagement
and in the end it funds my Jimmy Choo and Louis Vuitton obsession.